la publicité ça marche pas sur moi vous
avez tout à fait raison c'est même pour
ça qu'on dépense tous les ans des
milliards dans la publicité pour ce
jeudi
hors sujet j'avais envie de voir
pourquoi la publicité ça fonctionne sur
nous sur quel point ça se base en 2004
quand le lait était le pdg de tf1 il
avait déclaré dans une interview nous
vendons du temps de cerveau disponible à
coca cola et c'est tout à fait l'idée
ils veulent nous cueillir un moment
donné on est disposé à recevoir des
informations supplémentaires et inutile
ce qui veut dire qu'à l'époque
pas sûr que ça ait changé depuis tf1
fabriquer des programmes qui nous
mettait dans un conditionnement un petit
peu végétatif pour qu'on puisse
accueillir la publicité laisse la
publicité rentrée en tout quand on
regarde le mode de consommation ni
population on se rend compte qu'elle
publicité fonctionne un des premiers
leviers c'est la comparaison sociale la
jalousie dans une de leurs chansons trio
disais ce qui ne sert à rien et rang
envié le voisin c'est tout à fait ça
qu'est ce qui va rendre envieux de
voisins et qu'est ce qui nous rend
envieux nouna plupart des personnes ont
envie d'être dans la norme quels
l'admette ou pas au delà d'être dans la
norme elles ont envie d'être au dessus
de la norme d'être unique d'être
complètement différent et ça les
publicitaires l'ont bien compris
un autre levier qui fonctionne bien
c'est le rappel c'est le fait de revoir
une marque un logo ou un slogan sous
différentes formes et à différents
endroits par exemple dans un magazine on
publicité télé jusqu'à revoir le produit
en tête de gondole dans un magasin vous
l'aurez vu souvent il aura fait partie
de votre quotidien vous le connaissez
voire même vous le reconnaissez vous
avez peut-être déjà établi un petit lien
de confiance parce que si on le voit
partout c'est qu'il ya bien une raison
tout le marketing et le marchandising de
la publicité joue sur un troisième
levier qui et l'égocentrisme
vous allez être plus fort vous allez
être plus puissant vous allez être plus
attirants vous allez être plus efficace
vous allez plus quelque chose qu
apparemment vous êtes déjà si vous allez
être encore plus beau ça signifie
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes déjà beau on
flatte l'ego et on nous fait croire
qu'on va être encore mieux
mais n'oubliez jamais que nous ne sommes
pas ce qu'on possède donc ce qu'on
possède n'est pas ce qu'on n'essaie pas
le fait d'acheter un produit qui va vous
rendre cool un produit n'a jamais rendu
cool personnes ou t'es cool ou t'es pas
cool pareil pour l'intelligence la
beauté le courage ce que vous voulez on
ne peut pas acheter des valeurs on ne
peut pas acheter un état d'esprit ça
peut être cool de posséder quelque chose
mais le fait de posséder la chose ne
nous rend pas cool
un autre levier que nos amis
publicitaire aiment utiliser
avec plaisir force et conviction c'est
le conditionnement associatif et
l'appartenance appartenir à un groupe à
une communauté on est comme ça nous les
êtres humains on aime bien former des
clans on aime bien formés des teams
hashtag team menthe à l'eau on aime bien
se regrouper donc ils vont essayer de
nous faire croire qu'on va faire partie
d'un groupe intéressant en possédant ce
qu'ils voulaient nous vendons il ya
quelques années peut-être moins
aujourd'hui il y avait vraiment les
apple et les windows et il y avait
vraiment un petit groupe moi je
travaille sur mac ouais c'est assez un
autre monde on se sent plus libre 1 puis
ça plante jamais parce que yahya jammeh
de virus et tu vois ccc cher surtout
c'était très cher mais les arguments
étaient vendus eux mêmes par les
utilisateurs
il était tellement fier d'appartenir à
ce groupe fiers de leur appartenance qui
faisait le job de commercial derrière et
c'est un serpent qui se mord
complètement la queue puisque quand la
personne parle de la marque ou de
l'objet qu'elle a acheté que lui vendait
la publicité elle va elle même défendre
des valeurs qui était encore plus forte
que les valeurs initiales de la marque
pourquoi parce que ça améliore le
message qu'elle renvoie d'elles mêmes
on se fait tout savoir à petit ou à dose
mais personne ne peut dire je résiste à
100% aux messages des publicitaires par
contre quand vous devez acheter quelque
chose que ce soit un produit ou de
l'alimentaire fait un comparatif ne vous
fiez plus au packaging aux publicités
que vous avez vu et soyez forcément
pragmatique vous regardez le prix
regardez où est-ce que c'est fabriqué
vous regardez les caractéristiques
globales de l'appareil
c'est le meilleur et voire même le seul
moyen de faire des actes d'achat
complètement rationalise et puis si vous
avez envie de craquer pour quelque chose
et que vous craquez c'est pas grave non
plus merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé ce
hors sujet du jeudi j'espère que ça vous
aura plu si c'est le cas n'oubliez pas
de laisser et c'est pas une pub un
énorme pouce en l'air demain je
mentalise l'un ou l'une d'entre vous je
fais le tirage au sort ce soir à 20h et
j'enregistre avec la personne à 21h via
skype si vous voulez participer si vous
voulez peut-être vous faire mentaliser
dans la vidéo de demain alors aller voir
le dernier poste que j'ai mis sur la
fanpage de facebook vous avez le lien de
le descriptif avec de toute manière tous
mes autres réseaux sociaux passé une
excellente journée n'oubliez pas de
laisser un petit commentaire je les lis
tous même si en ce moment j'ai un petit
peu moins le temps de répondre je les
lis vraiment tous n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner avant de partir et rendez vous
demain à 17h ciao